what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today is
moon night day tonight at 12 a.m pacific
time moon night is coming out on disney
plus and reminder
don't forget about my watch party we are
starting them up again we're probably
going to start around 11 30 p.m pacific
time tonight so be sure to tune in we'll
be watching it together then of course
i'll be having my after party discussion
talking about what we just watched now i
fortunately have been blessed to be able
to see the first four episodes of moon
night no spoilers in this review this is
my review won't be talking about
spoilers obviously the first episode
hasn't really
come out yet by the time you're watching
this in the morning it's before
and i don't want to spoil anything
obviously but this is my review what i'm
going to be talking about here is the
overall arc of the show what i think of
it so far how it's violent how it's dark
how it's funny and how the acting is
phenomenal now right away
you do kind of feel a horror vibe when
watching moon night and it's not too
much because i know some people have
been asking me like well i don't really
like horror i don't really like horror
either and it's not too much by any
means but it is definitely a different
feel
that i actually welcome marvel studios
has managed to
continuously make
amazing movies and shows
that aren't exactly the same as what
we've seen before and i think they're
even better at that now this truly is a
different show never before have we
really addressed any type of mental
illness in the marvel cinematic universe
but hey as you've seen from the trailers
this shouldn't be a spoiler there's more
than one person inside oscar isaac's
body there mark spector
there's steven grant you know i'm not
gonna say any anything else past that
about his mental illness because they'll
talk about it during the the show but it
is cool to see him
switch between
stephen
and mark it it's really cool and i have
to praise oscar isaac because it's
phenomenal acting i mean he's a
phenomenal actor everything that he's
been in is truly
pretty dang good i don't think i've ever
walked away thinking oscar isaac didn't
really do a good job he's done a
fantastic job and he brought that into
moonlight which is great because he's in
the mcu now and i hope this character
stays around for a really really long
time but the way he can just
switch it and steven grant mark spector
like it's really really cool and i give
him a lot of praise for that same thing
with ethan hawk
speaking of like that horror aspect like
ethan hawk's character is a cult leader
that's what he is and
it's kind of creepy but he's also
charming which makes it even more creepy
because it's like wow this guy's like so
so creepy he's like leading this cult
but he's also very charming which
is also creepy because that makes him
better at what he does it makes people
more susceptible to following him
and you'll see how that all plays out
within the first couple of episodes now
the first two episodes the first one is
very much a
hey let's introduce everybody um let's
introduce who moon knight is let's
introduce you know mark specter
stephen grant you know basic introduce
you know it's the start it's the pilot
uh but it's still it's really really
good i'm not saying it's not a good
episode but the second episode it really
kind of like really picks up
and in the third and fourth episode
that's when things kind of like i'm like
wow
i'm in the show i was in it from one and
two but like when three and four hit
you're like
okay
all right we're here this is moon night
this is violence this is this is humor
this is uh this is dark it's different
than
what the mcu was offered before
and that's really really really good
now
i want to say it is dark and it does
have this horror aspect to it but it is
different than one division because some
people say well you know we started with
one division that kind of introduced the
supernatural side and yes i i totally
agree it brought in agatha harkness they
showed us the salem witches and they
showed us some dark magic right
this is different it's filmed different
because one division still was like
filmed
like a marvel project which of course it
was but this has some scenes where it's
like wow that's um that's different like
cinematically we haven't seen that from
marvel studios and there there's a lot
of parts that truly are creepy
especially with conchu we've seen some
of those parts in the trailer you're
sitting there like wow like
this is actually it's creepy now one
thing i will say something that i truly
love is this show's ability to bring you
in and get invested in it this is the
stuff that like we had for one division
when we were talking about mephisto and
like everything that was going to happen
at the end there was so much
anticipation because we didn't actually
know what was going to happen same thing
with loki we thought kang but we're like
wow what is actually
going on here are the timekeepers real
etc etc this does that with steven grant
mark mark specter moon knight this does
this really well because yes he's got a
mental illness yes there's you know
multiple personalities dissociative
identity disorder going on and you're
like
he thinks he's going crazy and then you
question like well is he
is is this real is konchu real or is he
making this up in his mind is it not
real it it really does grab you and make
you think that which really had me kind
of like on the edge of my seat because
i'm like i want to know i want to know i
want to know you know is he just gone
mad which i think is something he says
at some point or
you know
is he really the avatar of of konshu the
egyptian moon god um and i will say like
all the egyptian stuff pulled into it i
find that really cool i've always find
that pretty fascinating myself and uh
it's it's really good now i will say
show's pretty funny
and it's again to oscar isaac he stephen
grant as a character
is really really funny and it's like
it's funny because
you like him so much but you're kind of
laughing at him at the same time because
you know he's kind of this quiet
reserved shy guy you know people kind of
don't remember his name and you've seen
in the trailer like his boss kind of you
know
makes fun of him teases him a little bit
and you like feel bad for him but then
he does things you just like you laugh
at him and the humor really does come
from him and oscar isaac's performance
and i must say
it's it's it's pretty dang good now
action
there's a decent amount of action in it
i actually like how the first episode
kind of kicks you off with some of the
action i like how it ends with some of
the action and then when we get into the
second episode it really picks it up and
like i said the third and the fourth are
like woof like
we're getting into it now but
it's a good combination i think of like
cgi and hand-to-hand combat like i i
think that's really really good now you
are going to see some scenes that um
will be
not familiar but will
will feel
familiar we haven't seen them before but
you're gonna think like wow is this tied
into this
is it tied into this which again is
really really cool because
this show does not mention like anything
else in the mcu at all nothing else
right there's no like oh yeah captain
america did that you know
it's just nothing with the exception of
the marvel studios logo
you would probably not know this is a
marvel studios property
which is kind of cool because i think
obviously it's connected right it's moon
night i hope he goes on to become an
avenger or something west coast avenger
defender or some says you know something
they could throw them anywhere midnight
suns um
but it but it's it's disconnected and
that's actually what oscar isaac and
ethan hawk said kind of drove them to
this project is that it's actually
pretty disconnected from the mcu and i
actually like this because i do think
eventually maybe in the last episode
they're gonna pull something in maybe in
a post-credits scene we'll see you know
dr strange say he's recruiting for the
midnight suns and again
what this shows us
is that
a pg-13 movie can actually be kind of
brutal it's a show but i'm speaking of
if there's like a midnight suns movie or
something like that coming on it doesn't
have to be rated r it can kind of push
that boundary of violence and kind of
horror and creepiness without actually
going to rated r because i don't think
marvel studios wants to do that key
point doctor strange the multiverse of
madness is supposed to be the first
horror project from marvel or it should
say horror movie because moon knight is
coming out before and it's got major
horror vibes but it's pg-13 and i think
they're going to do this extremely well
to the point where they don't have to go
to the rated r because i know there's
probably a lot of younger viewers who
won't be able to watch them if they're
rated r and they are keeping those
people in mind but overall
i really like this i really really
really like this series i think it's
going
to be people's favorite
some people i think some people will say
you know it's like a top three or
something like that um i'm gonna have to
wait till i see
the last two final episodes to decide
for myself
but if you're watching this after you
watch the first episode let me know what
you thought and if you haven't watched
it yet if you're here before let me know
how excited you are for it because i'm
really excited for everybody to watch it
seriously from the violence to the
action to the horror aspect to the
psychological thriller aspect of it and
to its comedy
it's a pretty great show and i'm really
really excited for everybody to watch it
so let me know how excited you are in
the comments down below don't forget to
stop by the watch party tonight don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all things
mcu for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you